yo kinda went to welcome to this video I
really hope I'm stopping this series of
losses three versus three losses in a
row and and how someone places opening
oh my god yes never think never remotely
consider here whatever anyway let's just
see that I can better win this game okay
talk bad for black somehow this position
was a bit weird but this is not a bad
position c4 maybe yeah that's not good
not welcome all you needed him somehow
hmm
that's an extremely extremely annoying
move sorry all kinds of things probably
work maybe just rip the ADA something i
don't know mckenna that you create is
probably not my biggest issue
see who i mean if i take at least I get
to be four for my night
queen is no attacked
Wow
ok the night is now hanging if I move it
I will take on a three PG to go see
Bonnie for okay I also had to check on
v3 and then take on b7 am I losing
against this I don't see why ok so lets
him
smoking age 8 and I take it so look f8
of caution in black is probably losing
your exam it yeah quite obviously lots
of things against my king even though if
I take here get rid of the this attacker
I mean book takes to taking a couple of
times i go to g one that should should
should hold
yeah maybe that's a draw actually but I
don't have to take the rook I mean I can
go here there's nothing wrong with this
first go to g1 I also could have taken
on a three anyway I don't think there's
something wrong with this ok and if I
now we'll take the note take I'm really
really cautious there because I keep
spoiling games like this so try to be
circumspect so just this cover color you
three
okay currently this is all covered d 2
is an idea if i go here due to I can
take I just need to get the Queen back
and help it he'll help on Queen should
help with with the defense okay that I
have to take
okay so needs to take on f4 with the
rook can also know I cannot move the
night yeah I really shouldn't do that
time or 96 like it could flame
can take our foil cream shakes what
exactly is my move then group takes 2-3
know yeah just just stupid move just a
stupid move okay come on take the night
clingy six loop t3 so that my stuff is
coordinated finally really so terrible
[Music]
yeah come on check check check check
check check check check check check
probably probably this is too willing to
spoil ya might manage perfectly okay
then I'm taking okay okay Jeff game
drawn I really ran a long time
really oh my god what would what is this
sometimes this really just shouldn't
play yeah I mean some days I just so
rotten it I mean what what is this what
is this game I mean I had lost three in
a row so the letter really takes a toll
on you or I can just do this until
resign set square that's cute so that
Queen g5 fancy move didn't work out come
on I'm just so bad piano tf2 is great
again pretty falling sir this is all the
more bunch of nonsense yeah that doesn't
work I kept continuously win yeah I mean
I'm just an idiot this oh my god yeah I
mean of course that doesn't work out oh
my god check this is crazy I mean this
is also of course completely Korean
because I'm just up everything I mean
everything I'm a look and a piece of
here and now all the haul trucks are
pretty terrible and it said okay I know
this is a completely inning-ending ass
ready sega check and check check check
sauce no I don't know what it is okay
okay dead chickens pretty use this to
give our hit now every seconds I mean
it's easy it's really easier just
attempt to move and promote okay yeah
I'm gonna have no time preciate is the
man ok NP i check hello yeah what did
you play mate now oh come on
ok anyway